hey welcome to new project camp video
so in this video we're gonna talk about
our problems or challenges and we're
gonna do a q a for you guys that don't
know this yet uh this is something we do
every eight videos so number eight 18 28
38 and now we're in number 48. before
we're gonna look at our new challenges
and problems let's have a look at the
ones we had before which was a little
bit about taking a break
so the problem we had before that we
were making videos weekly for a year and
it got a bit intense
so the problem is we won't be able to
keep it up like this because few reasons
first is
one week is short to do and something
meaningful and film and edit that in the
same week it's intense and we also just
really needed a break so we were
proposing to take a break and next year
come with the video maker and we got
some interesting reactions to that for
instance from frankie s i would not let
the youtube channel go dark for a few
months
and well done i think it's a bad idea
you must keep the content flowing to be
successful
yeah the algorithm punishes inactive
channels heavily
maybe still make a short video each week
to keep the algorithm happy not going to
post videos for several months is a
mistake
it's a huge mistake
you should make more videos your channel
is going to suffer if you quit the
algorithm you will kill your page so
yeah quite a few alarming comments
some are also positive but generally it
felt like kind of a risky thing to do to
just leave the channel and hoping after
a while you guys are still here the
algorithm is still good
um so yeah but as jeremy nacional acres
at [ __ ] the algorithm don't let tools
misshape you
we agree
so yeah here we are now a few months
later and before we had about 50 000
subscribers when we took a break and now
we're back and we actually got this
thing from youtube reaching a hundred
thousand subscribers
we actually now have over two hundred
and fifty thousand to go out before we
send this thing
so uh yeah that's good and also the
first video we posted after this long
break had over three million views by
now which is by far the most used we
ever had on the video
so the reason why i'm sharing this is
mainly to say that i think many makers
would have this thing that you feel
trapped by an algorithm you need to do
something to keep it energized and to
keep content flowing but i would say
it's worth it to take a break so maybe
useful for other makers or ourselves in
the future again make sure you put the
energy in yourself not the algorithm
all right so now let's get on with our
problems we have now
challenges
all right first challenge electricity
lines or you might think uh silly again
like the highway sounds now they don't
like the electricity lines yes
highway sounds are still annoying and
electricity lines is also something but
let me explain
so when we bought the land we knew there
would be electricity lines on it we have
a line here and a line there in the back
and but they were not very visible fully
overgrown so sort of there but you
didn't really see it but now recently
they cleaned up this entire line and
the other one they will do as well
because to prevent fires they need to
make sure they keep a distance cleared
around the poles for 15 meters
so this makes it super visible and open
where the electricity lines are
so it makes sense to prevent the fire
but realistically is not very beautiful
and this is a bit of a challenge for us
because you might think i just need a
crystalline but if you ask around nobody
really wants to live underneath there so
for us it affects quite a lot how we
deal with the landscape and where we
organize the housing
and because one part the other line is
actually quite beautiful calm area which
would be great to live but with the
electricity line very visible there
comes a bit less interesting
so we need to rethink a bit our planning
and in the end it's kind of boring
because we don't even use them we have
solar-powered electricity
so challenge to work with
so another challenge probably a bigger
one is fire risk so this land burned
down uh twice in the recent years
and it's quite likely to happen again
and this wasn't really an issue for us a
few or last year because we just arrived
to the land everything was growing a bit
it was kind of rainy
and we didn't really build anything but
as we are here longer and we built
certain structures the vegetation
started growing so there's more material
to burn
and it starts to worry a bit more and
knowing the history of the land and also
knowing that this year it rained much
less last year was rainier this one less
much drier so with a hot summer coming
up
it's uh yeah the risks are increasing
and also if you really think about it
like on this land you have a bunch of
trash laying around
and broken glass and bottles and even
that the refractoring of the glass could
cause a fire by funneling the light to a
specific point
which can cause a fire and anything man
there's so many pieces of glass laying
around so much hot sun so much dry
material to burn how can this not burn
down or how can we not even do something
stupid with a grinder or a chainsaw or
spark that we caused to burn everything
down
so yeah more and more on our head to
think about it but it actually feels
somewhat of a challenge that is also
good and we knew the challenge would
come when we bought this land and that
the risk was there but it also felt like
a very useful thing to figure out how
can you really prevent forced fires what
to do when there is one because this
problem of wildfires is getting more and
more around the world and becomes more
and more of an issue
and so hopefully we find a good
solutions for it
we actually started a research topic in
a website where you can follow the
process we make step by step and you can
give input if you have suggestions on
how to deal with this so hopefully in a
few years we figured it out and
we were not scared of it anymore it's
not a challenge
all right on to the last challenge
all right and the last challenge is the
people
because uh everyone is super nice and
friendly and they all fit in well and
they do the jobs and they like to do
them
but the challenge is actually that
everyone comes for a small amount of
time so people sign up for a certain
period and after that they leave
and this is actually quite intense have
people coming and going on a regular
basis because if a person comes it takes
a while before they're integrated before
they understand the systems how it works
get a bit into the routine
understand the job and then finally do
it
and having them leaving again feels kind
of heavy
also because it's a small group so you
really get to know each other
and because it's such a small group you
feel it very well when someone comes or
leaves
and hopefully this would change a little
bit in the future as we are going to be
with more people because now we're
currently with on average with 10 people
but in the future this would increase so
if you are here with 30 people you would
feel it less when a person comes and
goes
but i guess we didn't really expect this
up front to be honest that it would feel
that heavy to integrate new people and
say goodbye and integrate and say
goodbye
so we're actually also going to change
this instead of now the minimum of one
month to come we're going to increase
this to two months
until the end of the season
to really
yeah have people stay longer which i
think is better for us here and but also
for the people that come and go that
they really have more time to land and
really emerge into this space
so yeah i think this challenge will be
solved but i guess it's one we didn't
really foresee
so yeah those were the challenges we
currently have and now we're going to go
to the next part which is q a
okay q a from you guys some questions
asked
first we're gonna start with some
questions asked on patreon because our
patreons are special no offense youtube
people you could become a patreon if not
you're also cool but patrons are just a
bit more special
so first question
hey i'm wondering what your approach to
languages are you learning portuguese
and what language do you communicate
with each other yeah i'd say english is
the main language
we prefer people speak portuguese
but many don't what are some of the cool
things effects you didn't expect when
the new people arrived i think it was
really cool to see the place that it
just works the systems we set up the
infrastructure
and it's a nice place for people to be
and what a work electricity works
so i think that was super nice and also
yeah the place just feels better like
just being the two people on the land
just a bit isolated it's nice to have
people around i was wondering what
experience professions or education
everyone working on on project camp has
so i studied industrial design
and i'm now a product designer
and i'm running a gym okay so i'm
originally a teacher
literature and drama
that's my education at university
i've worked as a teacher for a year and
since then i haven't
i'm a massage therapist and a yoga
teacher i studied graphic design
and my profession is filmmaking and
animation and a bit of graphic design as
well
my profession is
product designer maker
something like this
um
i don't know if it's my
profession but my education
is based on many years of community
living
and also i studied quite some
physical theater
what's the chocolate situation in the
camp it's alright
how are you preparing for a potential
upcoming wildfire do you have some ideas
in mind how to protect the campsite with
wildfire approaches
yeah so we already talked about this
before in our challenges uh very much on
our mind we don't really know yet we do
actually have next week we're gonna go
friends to the fire department to have
an interview with them to really ask
what's it like here when a fire occurs
what to look out for so we're very much
now in the moment of sourcing that
information and trying to understand
more of it but again if you have
suggestions or ids make sure to go to
our research module
i'm wondering if you have any idea where
project camp should be in season five
multiple villages strong cooperation
with the people you visited the
neighborhood
families and kids living there to be
honest no idea
we sort of have a rough ideas in our
head what could be cool
but it feels like it's really hard to
plan and work toward this it's more like
anticipating with whatever we learn and
discover and try to incorporate that
into the plan
so we don't really have a 10-year plan
if that's where we want to be it
gradually shapes as we spend more time
here and we keep on developing so yeah
not sure how it's going to go let's see
if i remember well last year you
scratched the barca for mimosas trees
hoping it would kill them what's the
result
so here you have one of the mimosas
with the bark here and here we stripped
off the bark
because apparently they would then die
this one still looks pretty live
also that one and that one
are stripped but they're also still
alive
so yeah not sure yet
i was wondering if the whole makita tool
environment is working for you guys
yeah i would say so far so good uh it's
convenient but then again we only really
tested the makita environment
and i guess every supplier has their own
environment
but we'll do a more in-depth review
actually soon about also the chainsaw
and the brush cutter we used for a while
it's probably better to wait for that
video how is the toilet working is it
enough for people currently there
your toilet works with a
bucket
where you make your
thing in
and no flush and sawdust and works quite
well
no smell no flies
it's cool
our toilet
perfect
the toilet's working well
beautifully
we don't have a traffic there never
i never bumped into another person
is doing fine the only difficult thing
is that you cannot pee while you poo
so it's sometimes a bit tricky how's the
solar panel system and the clay oven
after the last update i would say both
are pretty good especially the solar
surprisingly stable
not really problems with it clay oven
had a big crack in it
still works but that's the only downside
but so far they're both holding up very
well will you have water from the
waterfall and wind power for the winter
we recently installed a little wind
meter in base camp to see if we can if
it makes sense that we get enough wind
here to even install a turbine
waterfall it's not on our land so
probably wouldn't do anything soon there
and you also really need to pull the
cable all the way from the creek here so
something like wind in base camp would
be easier but maybe in the long term
actually if we establish more towards
the creek
we would use it as well but it's still
to be figured out actually so if also
that has enough capacity grandpa
mentioned about the lagoon is it still
up there and can you show us
so here's the waterfall and the lagoon
should be up there
but let me get closer
so we're now on top of the waterfalls
flowing down here
and apparently the lagoon should be all
around here
but to be honest we've never seen it
because it's just too much vegetation
here
you can barely see the water on the
floor flowing
so
yeah not sure yet where it is maybe in
summer we'll find it
what are your plans for the big room you
helped to recover in episode 46
episode 46 was actually our small ruin
we have a bigger ruin as well and the
plan for the small ruin is to turn it
into a guest house in the long term and
in the short term it would be a little
house for us for the winter to stay warm
but yeah for the guest house it would
mainly be so experts from around the
world can come with their specific
expertise and we can offer them a good
place to stay and then they can
contribute their knowledge to the
project
that would be the goal of the guest
house did you already test the water
from the well in a lab is it drinkable
yes we test it
it's drinkable depending how you see it
but we actually next video you can see
the results of that and what we did
where does everyone sleep i sleep here
in a proper bed the mattress
and inside this
yellow box which is my van i sleep in a
tent on the floor
i sleep in a van in a tent in my vents
in the fan
have you ever tried cooking moroccan
food in the camp
moroccan food
i don't not here
before in life yes here no
what happened to the highway noise
problem still there funny fact actually
that when the new people arrived it
wasn't really a thing for them they
didn't really notice it too much and
also me and vita ourselves we noticed it
much less
i think it's the upside that has having
more people around just many other
noises that sort of
makes you forget about the highway noise
which is quite nice actually but it's
still in the morning you hear it a lot
when it's rush hour and everyone is
quiet that's still
maybe we need to make more noise in the
morning i also wanted to ask how do you
guys honestly feel about this are you
guys scared nervous happy or is it just
go with the flow type of thing
yeah i think it's exciting to build this
thing and you really don't know what
you're building because there isn't a
10-year plan so
it's very much uh
easy going and exciting to see
every time what would come next what's
your favorite and least favorite thing
about camp
um
to think about this
my favorite is the people
my least favorite is also the flies
[Music]
my favorite thing would
be the people
and my least favorite thing would be
there are not many flat surfaces around
my favorite thing is probably the pizza
nights friday night
my least favorite thing
is
the water system reassembling the water
i think my favorite thing is the or are
the animals here around like you have
here lizards a lot of lizards snakes
mice
and eagles
and all that stuff
and my least favorite thing is maybe the
immense amount of noise which can happen
here around the camp from all the
construction site and the saws and
thrilling and sanding and stuff can be
very intense
i guess my favorite thing here
is
the concept of the project
my least favorite thing is
the sounds of the cars
favorite
it's all the lush green around here
and all the different
kind of environments it's a rocky part
which is more bushes in this and like
here little creek with
there's a lot of green
growing
a lot of different plants really like
this
which i don't like
that i don't speak portuguese
to communicate with the
how do you earn money to sustain your
lifestyle lifestyle is pretty basic like
we don't really have bills like rent
electricity is free water comes from the
land
the main things we have is buying for
food and development or really building
things
and the food and the sort of reoccurring
costs come from youtube you guys
watching videos gives enough money to
sustain us
and then the actual development like
bigger projects we take on we rely on
donations
are you using the wind oil to make
kitchen oil we'd love to see it in
action oh wow that's that's old school i
know we're not using that at the moment
would be cool to test it or make a
version 2 out of it but at the moment no
do you plan to take a break from the
channel again next winter or keep the
channel going uh yeah planning to do a
break again we really like it to just do
a lot of work in season and then reflect
zoom out and think what would be the
next steps so yeah very much in our mind
to have the break again what happened to
the giant table from the boating club
so the boating table is right here in
our white tent it's now just holding
stuff it's kind of useful but the main
reason is because we don't have enough
dry space outside big enough for the
table would fit so
it's a bit of a shame but hopefully
later we can put it somewhere properly
i'd like to know how you organize
yourself do you have a daily or weekly
meetings to discuss your current plans
and situation so right here we have our
weekly schedule
so on monday morning we have a meeting
at 10 a.m with everyone together to say
what they're going to do this week
and then throughout the week and we have
maybe some things popping up since
potato harvest with the neighbors
then on friday we have a cleanup and a
maintenance we do a weekly recap
altogether to see how the week went
and there's pizza night and on saturday
and sunday we don't work
and breakfast times are here
so this is kind of our weekly schedule
do you guys planning of what to achieve
in every season like in this season
season two and three yeah so we don't
really have this 10-year plan mapped out
what we want to achieve but that's kind
of where the seasons are very crucial
for us because we plan something in the
winter and then we execute it in the
summer and then we reflect and plan
again in that next winter so seasons are
very important for us to make sure we
reflect we pivot and we set course for
the new season can we come and help in
the summer certainly you can go to the
website on the support section and then
you can donate your workforce so you can
see different ways how you can help out
to sign up what are the requirements one
needs in order to be part of this
beautiful project so for the short term
you just go to the website sign up if
you want to help out for the long term
we're not really sure yet we hope it
goes organically like people come if you
like it they like it
they sort of stick around and naturally
become long-term people so it's not like
a thing you sign up for and then you're
in or out
hoping for an organic process do you
have some rule
yeah we have a bunch of rules uh like
for instance we eat vegan during the
week or we don't use heavy machinery on
sunday so it's more of a quiet day with
a bunch of these rules
um
but i would say they're also we call
them more guidelines because they're
somewhat flexible
because we don't know what would be the
best rule but it's more of a guideline
that everyone sticks to this
should be a coherent good nice place to
be and we also see this a bit like every
season we reflect on the rules maybe we
try something completely different maybe
the same maybe we rethink it a little
bit
so it's a good way to sort of gradually
shape a bit the guidelines of this place
i was wondering how do volunteers that
don't live in portugal or nearby get to
the camp it depends this is generally on
the people themselves some are already
around some are traveling some come with
a van so they have to drive it here if
you come from south africa you come with
a plane
so it depends a bit on each person
quite diverse what's the hardest thing
for you at the moment living this
lifestyle
is that there's not so much um
private space
and i like to be by myself quite a lot
the hardest thing is the being together
all the time
not having a
a means of transport
so just like relying on feet to get feet
or lifts from other people to get around
the tent
i don't know i just know this lifestyle
it's maybe the mixture of all
like the intensity of a community and a
lot of work and
being always on the same place with the
same people is quite challenging for me
what is your governance model meaning
how do you make decisions and deal with
conflict
so far it's been quite easy i would say
not much conflict i think it's mainly
because we really set out a plan in the
beginning of the season with the longer
term people we all agree on that and
then we just execute it during the
season
and the little decisions that come up
them we can quite quickly resolve them
in the group
so far uh and i guess in winter we might
have a few more heavy decisions coming
up again but uh man i guess we'll see
this winter but so far we can just
consensus we talk about it everyone
agrees good
how do you guys protect yourself god
forbid what if there's an intruder or
teeth how do you deal with that place is
pretty open yeah i think in general we
don't worry about this too much
it is very open i guess someone could
just walk in
and take stuff but it feels very
friendly here the neighborhood people so
we just have faith that nothing bad will
happen compared to last season why
season two is a bit boring what's the
reason
i don't know the weather
do you guys have a faith or religion if
so why and what region i think we all
have faith in mankind and earth and
being able to solve problems we have
faith in that religion
not that i'm aware of
we don't really talk about this it's not
very interesting i think to us
um
how many of you speak portuguese and how
many of the local people understand
english portuguese rita is portuguese so
she's the master and then we have some
people from spain which are a bit better
in the portuguese
so everyone has different levels
portuguese me not good at all and the
local people know english mainly
portuguese so there's always a bit of a
gap in between
i think the best thing we do is just
waving and saying
to project camp have a defined
philosophy vision rule their goals last
year you answer you didn't know what a
more sustainable way of living man do
you know now or just hanging around
waiting for boom
yeah waiting for boom
no i guess we still don't know and i
think we also like to keep the question
open because you probably don't have an
answer so i think the approach is just
trying to understand more of it each
year researching more testing more
trying more
and then maybe
20 years from now we have the answer
when i saw the white rice i really
wanted to ask if there's an asian on the
camp and as an asian to just want to ask
if it's possible to plant rice and camp
more power to you guys well you can grow
rice in portugal we don't really grow
things at the moment and we don't have
an asian person here right now but
we would like it all right so that was
it for this q a thank you for sending in
the questions it's really good for us
actually to understand also what is
unclear and it's fun to answer them
so we're going to do this again in the
next eighth video
so if you have questions keep them in
mind
and next week we're actually going to
finish up the yoga decks so
they're going to look very beautiful if
you want to see that video make sure to
support the patreon special people if
not no problem all cool we're gonna be
here again next week same time same
channel
thanks for watching and see you next
video